im netz gibt es jetzt große aufregungen
um ein instagram werbevideo von
volkswagen für ihr neuen golf viele
nutzer finden den spot geschmacklos und
rassistisch in dem video ist zu sehen
wie ein schwarzer mann für einer
überdimensionalen großen weißen hand
herumgeschubst wird
der neue golf im internet wird jetzt
also heftig über diesen spot diskutiert
rassistisch und menschenverachtend
finden viele user ihn
wir haben das denkmal die reaktion für
sie zusammengefasst der neue werbeclip
für den vw golf macht viele menschen
wüten das sind die vielen dinge die
rassistisch gedeutet werden können ein
dunkelhäutiger mann wird von einer
weißen hand herumgeschubst die user
schreiben dazu in der neuen werbung wird
rein zufällig ein schwarzer mann von
einer weißen handschuhen oder geschubst
hey volkswagen kurze frage warum macht
ihr eine solch rassistische werbung für
mich ist das weg schnipsen eines
menschen die dreck oder ein insekt der
eigentliche skandal
der dunkelhäutige mann wird ins
restaurant petit couronne geschubst
übersetzt heißt dies kleiner siedler die
user sehen eine anspielung auf den
kolonialismus und dennoch zufällig
diesen mann in den piccolo reinsteckt
weil ja kolonialismus wahnsinnig viel
mit autos verkaufen zu tun hat so im
jahr 2020
wie kann das alles zusammen aber keine
absicht sein allein schon diese schwarze
person ins hotel piccolo schubsen die
hand im video bietet beim schnitzen das
zeichen für white power ein
schlüsselbegriff in der neonazi szene
zum schluss einfach weiter zeichen white
power handzeichen bist auch dabei der
clip ist absichtlich so durchkomponiert
vw wurde dabei reingelegt aber ich gönne
es den am ende des spots erscheint der
text die ersten buchstaben sind rgm
die user schreiben wo soll hier ein
missverständnis sein eindeutiger geht
rassismus kaum ist das heftig krass da
glaube ich nicht mal mehr an ein
hochgradig inkompetentes medienteam
obwohl einige user auch argumentieren
dass alles ein missverständnis sei
überwiegt das negative feedback
volkswagen schämt euch
rassismus ist kein missverständnis
genauso wenig wie sexismus und
antisemitismus
ich kann mir leider nur sehr sehr schwer
vorstellen dass diese verkettung
unglücklicher zufälle niemanden bei vw
aufgefallen ist
das waren nur einige kommentare aus dem
netz es gibt immer noch tausende weitere
die sich über diesen instagram spot nun
auf regen natürlich hat volkswagen sich
mittlerweile entschuldigt
der vw vertriebschef jürgen stackmann
sagte zu dem video ganz ohne frage das
video ist falsch und geschmacklos er
sprach zudem von einem rassistischen
werbevideo das jeden anständigen
menschen beleidige und sagte weiterhin
dass schämen uns dafür und können es
heute auch nicht erklären
umso mehr werden wir dafür sorgen dass
wir diesen vorgang aufklären
alles was dann bei diesen untersuchungen
herauskommt die ergebnisse und
konsequenzen sollen dann öffentlich
gemacht werden
und auch vw betriebsratschef bernd
osterloh hat sich geäußert sagt ich
schäme mich für diesen sport da spreche
ich sicherlich für die ganze belegschaft
also es abzuwarten was nun dabei
rauskommen wie es zu diesem werbeclip
kommen konnte mir doch sehr vielen
fragwürdigen entscheidungen